hello everyone this is Satoru Iwata from
Nintendo Satoru Iwata story is one laced
with unbelievable risks bright thinking
and dark times and a bold ambition to
make a difference for all that can be
said about his charming mannerisms his
warm smile his unquestionable love of
video games it should not be overlooked
they owatta was a visionary businessman
who saved Nintendo by reinventing it he
was a radical force a revolutionary
figure who commanded a century-old
company as though it was his own startup
foreseeing a bleak future in retreading
old ground it were to took Nintendo down
the Uncharted path often with its future
hinging on little more than his peculiar
ideas those who believed in him were
rewarded with the most prosperous period
in the corporations proud history even
it was his appointment to the head of
Nintendo in 2002 was unconventional by
Nature
he was the company's very first elected
president who had no blood ties to the
Yamaguchi's the family that had founded
and managed in Tendo across three
generations his promotion came a bleak
hour for Nintendo with the Gamecube
languishing in the shadow of the
PlayStation 2 with retailers and
publishers abandoning the console little
more than a year into his tenure the
water had to warn investors that the
corporation had begun losing money but
in the same speech where he announced in
tendo's first half fiscal loss it were
to revealed plans for a new system that
would take the company on a bold new
direction the Nintendo DS was his first
major gamble a bizarre-looking handheld
that housed two separate screens in a
clamshell design it was the first
mainstream games platform to use a
touchscreen and stylus and one that
clearly prioritized how it felt over how
it looked the secret to the ds's
record-breaking sales was neither how it
played or looked however its success was
down to irritants belief that he could
ignite interest in people who didn't
typically play games so for every new
Super Mario Brothers and Mario Kart vs
released for the handheld there was also
the daily mental workout companion Brain
Age and the virtual pet simulator
Nintendogs the DS which underwent
several revisions throughout its 10
years on the market sold more than 150
million
it's Nintendo's handheld business which
some felt was doomed by the arrival of
Sony's PlayStation Portable had become
more prosperous than ever
even before the reveal of the Nintendo
DS at e3 2004 it was already had bigger
and bolder plans in place he said the
handheld should serve as a hint towards
our next-generation console but if you
would have predicted how far it was it
was prepared to go the second major
gamble the Wii was so radical so
implausibly different that it belongs in
a league of its own
rather taking a game show in September
2005 it were to took the stage and held
up a bizarre one-handed game controller
this was perhaps the defining moment of
his career a wild and arguably reckless
break from more than 30 years of
tradition what followed TGS 2005 was a
frenzy a fever of debate and speculation
and unforgettable excitement It was as
though the audience didn't know how to
react mr. Iwata said of his Tokyo Game
Show reveal while there were significant
reservations from some fans the sheer
enigma of the we had captured the
imagination of the gaming world the
console became the fastest-selling in
history brought games to entirely new
audiences and ushered in a new age of
motion control it would never reach that
height again the 3ds initially struggled
with a lukewarm reception to its
stereoscopic 3d as well as a declining
market handhelds for the Wii U is more
clear-cut failure another brave idea
certainly the one that did not connect
with the masses Nintendo like all
creative companies will stumble again
and again throughout its lifetime that
is a natural floor of any person or
company that dares to innovate that
dares to expose itself where Nintendo is
undoubtedly standing on far more solid
foundations now than it was 13 years ago
it was his legacy serves as a reminder
of how far one can go
if they never give up on their ideas
[Music]
on my business card I am a corporate
president in my mind I am a game
developer but in my heart I am a gamer
[Applause]
[Music]
you